[Musique]
jean françois bélanger médecin
psychiatre et musicien nick a l'air pas
son instrument médiévale à peu près
disparu de la carte où ces derniers
restaient quelques joueurs dans une
portion de la suède est lâché entendu
certains se marre et j'ai fait des mains
four
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les trois enfants on s'est fait offrir
en bas âge
quels instruments se veut apprendre et
de parents sont pas musiciens on earth
tour à tour choisi notin soit moi ça a
été le violon j'aimais beaucoup somme je
chantais que ce n'est pas dans mon
élément avec la musique classe et puis
finalement je tombais sur les musiques
traditionnelles et à partir de l'or mais
je mets à prendre plusieurs instruments
différents toujours un auto d'idées pour
explorer comment ça marche
enfin plus berlue h les temps anciens la
lie sur le département de musique
j'avais deux premières compositions
magique c'est qui qui joue bien de la
flottille et du violon la guitare on
allait les repérer met un peu inquiet
c'était cégep en spectacle une mission
embarquée les compositions plus on s'est
rendus effectivement finale nationale on
a gagné la tournée en bretagne c'était
ma première expérience web à l'étranger
il fallait faire un choix
j'ai finalement choisi des bons je vais
aller faire la médecine c'est plus dur
en très léger recul reste c'est quoi ce
que je voulais faire
et j'ai fait un premier stage en
psychiatrie le stage obligatoire
intéressant je vais aller en faire un
deuxième ça va mais dépend d'un médecin
de famille est là ça a été la plus
fructueuse et c'est bien sur mance je
vais avec un psychologue
en psychiatrie il faut être très
accueillants parce que les gens nous
confient les choses les plus intimes
j'ai vu
et c'est pas drôle allez dans les côtes
et plus difficile noir de son existence
longtemps j'ai vu ce très compartimenté
ok je fais de la musique c'est de la
musique les médecins c'est de la
médecine puis même je voulais pas les
mélanger les deux et dans le fond je
réalise plus haut depuis les dernières
années que c'est trés interconnectés on
se voit toujours mieux dans les yeux de
l'autre concevoir soi-même les sports
cependant qu on se dit souvent et en
musique c'est assez similaire d'une
communication et c'est cette fois la
porte parole
est ce qu'on a en voit on dans mes
compositions dans mon interprétation
ça génère des choses la personne des
images des souvenirs et les gens disent
beaucoup que ma musique est imagé
enfants en médecine ou et l'autre bleu
[Musique]